[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEWART REICHLING: Our talk is
Run Cloud Functions Everywhere.
My name is Stewart Reichling.
I'm the product manager
for Google Cloud Functions.
With me, I have--
JUSTIN GRAYSTON:
Justin Grayston.
I'm a custom engineer
based out of London,
specializing in telco media
and technology companies.
STEWART REICHLING: Cool.
After that, housekeeping.
Please rate the session
in your app afterwards.
We want to know whether
you liked it, whether you
hated it, what could be better.
Questions-- feel free
to shout them out,
or we'll have mics at the end.
You can also find us outside.
Answer anything that
you want to know.
Cloud Functions, who here
has heard of Cloud Functions?
Decent number of people, nice.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: That's not bad.
STEWART REICHLING: Pretty
much everyone, nice.
Who's actually used
Cloud Functions?
Also a lot of people--
OK, cool.
So we're going to talk about
stuff that should be hopefully
interesting to you
if you've already
used the product, and also some
sort of more fundamental stuff
if you don't really have
much experience with it,
just to make sure that we
have a common sort of base
of understanding about
what the product does.
So Cloud Functions--
what do I tell customers
when they ask me what it is?
One, serverless functions.
So it's a managed
compute environment.
It scales automatically
up and back down.
You don't get any requests.
You're not paying for it.
You don't manage infrastructure.
It's all a very seamless,
straightforward experience.
Part of that is this
streamlined development model.
You just write function code.
You issue one command.
We're going to walk through
that in a couple of minutes.
And then you get it running.
Very simple.
Also, events
integration-- so triggers
to have your function run.
You can send HTTP
requests, get posts.
You get a nice URL.
We'll show you that, too.
We also integrate very nicely
with different event sources
within Google Cloud Platform.
So for example,
Google Cloud Storage,
you get a file to that you
want to have your function run.
Just a very simple
example of type of events
integration that we
offer with this product.
I'm going to talk
through some of the stuff
that we announced at Next this
year because as the product
manager for Cloud
Functions, nothing
hurts me more than a customer
who comes up and says,
I really like Cloud Functions,
but you only support Node.
We support many
different languages.
This year at Next, we announced
Python 3.7 GA, Node 8 GA, Go
1.11 GA.
We also announced a private
alpha for Java 8 and Go 1.12.
I'm going to be putting up
links at the end of this session
with QR codes so you
can snap a picture,
get you signed up
for those as well.
Yeah, Node 10 also in beta--
the focus of this
talk is actually
going to be about Node 10.
But the main idea
here is we want
to provide a very
streamlined developer model.
It wouldn't really be
streamlined if we said,
you can only use Node.
We want to make sure that
your favorite languages, very
popular languages, are supported
because this whole experience
should be very streamlined,
simple, and familiar to you
as a developer who likes
one of these languages.
Second thing we announced--
so when we first
launched Cloud
Functions, we only
supported one region,
Iowa, US central one.
We announced three new
regions at Next last year.
This year, we announced
also London and Hong Kong.
We're going to be adding more
regions throughout the year.
We'd love to hear from you
where else you want functions.
This helps us prioritize
where we're going to next.
We also announced a feature
called max instances.
And these are basically
scaling controls
and the idea is when you
send traffic to a function,
we automatically spin
up new instances for you
to handle that traffic.
Sometimes that's great.
Other times, you might
want to control the degree
to which your function scales.
So a great example here is
you have a SQL database that
can only tolerate up to 10
connections at the same time.
Well, if you get 1,000 requests
to a function and each of those
hits your database, you
might break some things.
So max instances
allows you to say, hey,
only spawn 10 instances.
And that will allow
me to make sure
that my serverless
stuff works very
well with my non-scaling
non-serverless stuff.
The last feature
that is important
here is serverless VPC access.
And the idea here is Cloud
Functions traditionally
has not been able to communicate
with stuff inside of your VPC
network.
We now support
this feature, which
allows you to communicate with
your Google Compute Engine
instances.
Cloud Memorystore for
Redis is a huge one.
I hear from customers
all the time
that they'd love to be able to
support talking to their Cloud
Memorystore instances.
You can now access those
from Cloud Functions.
You can also access resources
in paired VPC networks
and on-premises networks that
you access through cloud VPN.
OK, enough recap about
the new stuff we launched.
Cloud Functions 101,
I'm going to walk you
through the developer experience
so that people can see what
is this thing actually about.
This is an example of a
function written in Node.js.
You export a function
called hello, World.
This specifically
is an HTTP function,
which means that we want
to make the experience very
seamless and very familiar.
So you get HTTP objects
that are familiar to you
as a Node developer.
Any Node developers
in the audience?
Yeah, a few.
OK, cool.
So this is based on Express.js.
Express is a popular web
application framework,
so request and response
are objects that are--
they're those objects
from that framework.
So this should all
be very familiar.
So you write this function.
It takes these arguments, and
then it sends a message back
to the caller--
Hello, Cloud Next.
Very simple, three
lines of code.
The next thing you do is you
want to deploy that function.
So we provide a
tool called G Cloud.
G Cloud is the tool that you
use to manage all of your Google
Cloud Platform resources.
You say G Cloud
Functions deploy.
My function name
here is helloWorld.
You specify that you want it
to use the runtime nodejs8.
And you specify a trigger.
This is the HTTP trigger.
It's going to give you
a URL, through which you
can access your function.
That looks something
like region project dot
cloudfunctions.net/helloWorld.
You can now visit
this in your browser.
You can curl it, and it will
respond back with that message.
And so what we showed you here
is it's super simple to get
started.
You write three lines of code.
You issue one command.
And from that,
you get this thing
that just kind of magically
works in the cloud.
It scales for you.
It does the sort of resource
based billing model where
you only pay for what you use.
And all you had to think
about was this tiny little bit
of code that you wrote.
So these are really
simple building blocks.
And you can build really
powerful things with them.
We see a couple of
different patterns
that customers often use.
I hear people ask me how should
I use this product, how should
I think about it.
So Justin, you want to talk
about some of the things
you see among customers?
JUSTIN GRAYSTON:
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, Cloud Functions are
really powerful and flexible.
But I think these
three areas are
where you see a lot of
customers using them,
event-based architectures.
So a company based
out of London,
a media company
called Seven Digital,
used Google Cloud
Storage triggers,
and then using that
with Cloud Functions
to create a complete new
content supply chain.
And you have another
pattern that I've
seen quite a lot is where
you're decoupling on-prem legacy
systems, which have been
tied to consumer-facing apps.
And now those systems, you
need to keep them around.
But they're at web scale.
STEWART REICHLING: Right.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: So by using
Pub/Sub and Cloud Functions,
you can then decouple
those systems.
STEWART REICHLING:
OK, so the idea here
is you write a
function, you deploy it,
you say, hey, I want this
function to run when somebody
maybe puts a file in
Google Cloud Storage
or when someone puts a
message on a Pub/Sub topic.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON:
Yeah, so let's say
somebody buys something, that
goes into a legacy database.
You then put that
transaction into Pub/Sub.
And then you can
have a Cloud Function
that runs and then puts
that into, say, Firestore,
which is a web scale database.
STEWART REICHLING:
Cool, awesome.
The other category we see
often is data processing.
So I talked to a company
out of Europe, In Farm.
They do really cool stuff
in the agriculture space.
They have farms distributed
throughout Europe.
And at each of these farms, they
have IoT sensors, small devices
that transmit messages
back saying what
the status is of those sensors.
And they use Cloud Functions
via a Pub/Sub topic
that carries that
sensor data to them.
They aggregate that data.
They put it in
different databases.
They put it in a
dashboard so that they
can see the status
of their farms
across different countries.
And so what you see here
is a very simple sort
of data processing model
where you get messages.
You're doing white ETL.
And then you put
those somewhere else.
Cloud Function is a great way
to glue that stuff together.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Yeah, and Cloud
Automation is another thing
that we've seen, is where you
have multiple cloud products,
and you may want to use
the Cloud Functions to glue
those products together.
So let's say, for
example, everything
is going into the
Stackdriver logs.
Somebody creates a
VM or a firewall.
You can create a filter and
create a sink in Stackdriver,
which goes to a Pub/Sub topic.
And you can tie your Cloud
Function to that Pub/Sub topic.
And that Cloud Function can
then check with Cloud Security
Command Center whether that's a
policy violation, for example,
whether a firewall has been
created that there is to open.
And then the Cloud Function
can then report that violation.
STEWART REICHLING: Cool.
Yeah, so Stackdriver, for
people who don't know,
is the suite of logging
and monitoring tools.
Pretty much all of
Google Cloud products
are very well
integrated with it.
The idea, again, is from a Cloud
Function or when a VM spins up,
I can go console
log some message.
Imagine like console log error.
I can then say, hey,
I'm going to filter
messages that contain error.
Based on those, do something.
Send maybe an email to
your security person
or to whoever is in charge
of reliability, send an SMS.
It's a very flexible way for
you to kind of glue together
your cloud products and
what you're doing in GCP.
But it all starts with
one simple, gcloud
deploy myFunction--
gcloud functions
deploy myFunction.
And this command looks
deceptively simple,
but it comes with a whole
bunch of cool stuff.
So for the price of one gcloud
command, what are you getting?
Clearly when you write
three lines of code and type
this one command, that's not
really enough for your function
to then be running in our cloud.
So what's happening
behind the scenes?
One is you have a build step.
During that build step, we
take your code, we upload it.
We then start a Cloud Build job.
Cloud Build id our
tool, our product that
allows you to build containers.
We install dependencies.
If you're a node
developer, it would
use NPM Install, which
is super familiar to you
if it's standard
Node.js tooling.
We add some code that
runs your function.
We're going to talk about
that more in a second.
And we build a container.
And our infrastructure
cloud functions
are really just
containers running
on our serverless
container infrastructure.
So the output of this step is
that you have a container image
that contains your code,
some additional code,
and your dependencies.
What happens next?
We deploy your function.
Your function-- we
take that container.
We're going to connect
a trigger to it.
So if you say HTTP, we're
going to give you a URL.
We're going to create an
instance of your function
that runs in our data center.
We then perform a health check.
We make sure that what
you gave us can actually
run on our infrastructure.
And then we start to migrate
traffic over gradually.
And so now you
have this container
that is ready to receive
requests on our infrastructure.
You wrote a couple
lines of code.
We built a container image.
We made sure it actually runs,
and now it's ready to run.
So the last thing
we do is we run it.
When you send traffic to
it, we route those requests
to your function.
We auto scale instances
of your function.
So if you're not
receiving any requests,
you have zero instances,
you're not paying for anything,
it scales down to zero.
You get a ton of
request, we're going
to scale up a whole
bunch of instances
to meet whatever
your QPS needs are.
We invoke your function
when a request comes in,
and we generate some
logs and metrics.
One of the challenges that
we hear from customers
is around
observability, and so we
want to make sure that when
you're using Cloud Functions,
you have a very easy way to
see what's actually going on.
What are the errors
that are generated?
What are the log statements
that you're outputting?
And so again, you went
from three lines of code,
one gcloud command to an
auto scaling function that
responds to inbound requests.
We handle a lot of the
gory details for you
so that this is
actually very simple.
And this is great
for most scenarios.
When you create a managed
product like Cloud Functions,
you want to try and
solve as many use cases
as you possibly can.
But often when you're
working on a project,
you might have one
specific need that kind of
falls outside of
the realm of what is
supported on Cloud Functions.
And it doesn't happen too
often, but when it does happen,
it's really annoying.
And your resolution
there often is--
I try to talk to
customers all the time.
The customer will come
to me and say, hey,
could you please add this
custom binary to my container?
Because I need to have
that run inside of it.
Well, the way Cloud
Functions is built today,
what actually would happen if I
put that custom binary in there
is that everyone's function
suddenly has that thing living
inside of their container.
Clearly that's not tenable.
If it's a hugely popular
binary, then yeah,
we'll add that to support
a lot of use cases.
But one single customer's
really specific
thing is hard to add because you
have to convince everybody else
that they actually want that.
So what if you actually
need more control?
What if you need more control
around building your function?
The example of a custom
binary is a great one.
You want to have something
run inside of it.
What do you do if the product
does not support that?
What do you do if you need
more control over deployments?
So as I mentioned,
Cloud Functions
is live in six
different regions.
What if you need
your function to run
in a very specific region for--
I don't know--
regulatory reasons?
What do you do if
your function needs
specific resources to run?
So a great example is
today on Cloud Functions,
we offer five different
instance types ranging in memory
from 128 megs all
the way up to 2,048.
Well, what if you need more?
What if you need more CPU?
What if you need GPUs?
Again, you could
send me an email
and say, hey, I'd really
love to support GPUs,
and I'll tell you, yes,
we'd love to do that too.
It might be six months
or a year from now.
Well, you need to solve
that problem today.
A great way to explain this
is to go back to the basics.
What is a function?
Well, as I explained earlier,
it's really just a container.
And that runs on our serverless
container infrastructure.
That infrastructure
is managed by Google.
Within that container, there
are a few different things.
One of those is an operating
system, Ubuntu in most cases.
And this is the value
of being on a managed
product, is that we patch
that operating system for you.
We make sure that,
the best we can,
there are no security
vulnerabilities in it.
All of that stuff gets
handled for you by us
when you're on a
managed product.
Inside of that container
is also a runtime.
In this example, it would
be the Node.js binary.
If you're writing
a Python function,
there's Python inside of there.
And again, that's managed
and patched by us.
On top of that, there's this
bit of code called the Functions
Framework.
And we're going to talk
about this in depth.
But the main idea is it manages
your function's lifecycle.
You gave us a couple
lines of code.
We put in an operating
system, a binary.
Clearly that's still not enough
to make your function available
and run it.
The Functions Framework
is what does that.
And then on top of that,
you've got your function code,
your dependencies.
This might look like a simple
Node.js function like the one
we have there.
You might have a
package JSON file,
which is what you use
as a node developer
to specify the dependencies
of your function.
And this is the part
that's managed by you.
Let's talk about this function's
framework a little bit more.
And just to be clear, this
stuff is available today.
It's a real thing.
It is now available
open source also.
So I'll talk about
that more in a second.
The Node.js 10 runtime
on Cloud Functions
is based on this
Functions Framework.
If you deploy a function
today to Cloud Functions
and you say runtime
Node.js 10, you're
going to get the runtime that
is based on this function.
It's available as
an NPM package.
NPM is Node Package Manager.
You can install it using
standard Node.js tooling.
And the source code is
all available in GitHub.
It's an open source project.
You can see it.
We've had people already
contributing issues, questions.
You can contribute commits.
We love full requests.
And the reason I put this
sticker on top about it now
being open source is
the Functions Framework
has always existed.
We haven't always called
it the Functions Framework,
but there's clearly
always been this code
that takes your function
and makes it runable.
Now we're making that more
of an open source-- we're
taking that in an
open source direction
where you have this package
which you can install if you
want to, and it's going to give
you some nice benefits, which
we'll walk you through.
And the code is also
fully inspectable
so that you could go up
and say, hey, actually,
this is a great idea.
I want to make
some slight tweaks.
I want to create my own thing.
Well, here's a great way
to get started with that.
So let's talk about exactly what
the Functions Framework does
so that you have a good sense
of, if I use this code, what's
it actually doing for me?
And I should also
mention that the stuff
I'm about to talk about--
if you take away two things
from this talk, it's, one,
the Functions
Framework is awesome.
The second one is that it's
completely optional if you're
using Cloud Functions.
So you can go on deploying
functions the way
you always have.
You don't have to actually
think about this stuff
or know about this stuff.
But if you do know about
it, it can give you
some nice benefits.
So we've got your container.
Within that container, we're
going to focus on these top two
layers.
The first one is
your function code.
We've already seen
this a few times now,
pretty straightforward.
It's an HTTP function, Node.js.
The Functions Framework manages
your function's lifecycle.
And what I mean by that is, OK,
the first thing it does is--
spoiler alert-- it's
actually just an HTTP server
under the hood.
You don't need to
know about that.
But that server, it exposes
your hello world function
on /helloWorld.
So if you send it a
request to /helloWorld,
it's going to run your function.
The second thing that this
function's framework does
is if you have a
client that sends
a request to your function,
it sends an HTTP request,
well, it's going to
take that HTTP request,
transform it into objects that
are specific to your language,
and it's going to invoke
and run your function
by passing it those arguments.
Again, these are
Express.js arguments.
For Python, these would
be Flask arguments.
For a different language, they
would be something different.
But it's very idiomatic.
It should feel extremely
familiar to a Node.js
developer.
So that function gets invoked,
passes those arguments.
Your function runs, and it
reaches that res.send block.
It's going to send that back
to the Functions Framework.
The Functions Framework takes
that, transforms it into HTTP,
and sends it back to the client.
So all this stuff is
pretty straightforward.
You could write this
stuff for yourself
with a couple hundred
lines of code.
Nothing too magical going on.
But the really
nice thing here is
I can just write this
function, deploy it, not
think about any of this stuff.
And I'm just thinking
about my function.
And why that's important
is that you really care--
the value you can
provide as a developer
is in the business logic,
in solving the problems
that your business faces.
You don't really
provide too much value
by writing an HTTP server,
and making sure it's exposed,
and handling, marshaling, or
unmarshaling of arguments.
All that stuff is important,
but it's not really
what you want to focus on
and spend your development
resources.
So that was a lot of talking.
Let's switch to a demo.
Justin is going to show
you what this actually
looks like in practice.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Yeah, OK.
So this is the biggest monitor
I think I'm ever going to have.
Is that all viewable?
Is that clear enough?
Yeah?
It's big enough?
So simple function.
You've seen this time and
time again in the deck.
Nothing fancy going on here.
We got a package.json,
node dependencies.
So it's as vanilla as
it can possibly get.
STEWART REICHLING:
Can I mention--
again, as a node developer,
none of this stuff
should be surprising to you.
This is a Node.js function.
It's an HTTP function, exactly
what we just showed you.
Package JSON is the file
that you use to specify--
it describes your
module or your function.
You can put
dependencies in there.
All of this stuff,
as a node developer,
should feel completely natural.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Yeah.
So first thing we're
going to do is we're just
going to deploy this function.
We're not going to do anything.
We've just got these
three lines of code,
and we're going to
deploy this out.
And I'm going to specify
the Node.js runtime.
STEWART REICHLING: You
can see it right here.
It's very nice.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: OK.
Talk amongst yourselves.
I'm regretting not having
a bash script right now.
OK.
So the runtime, and I'm going
to create and HTTP trigger.
STEWART REICHLING: And
this is using Node.js 10.
The slide I showed earlier
with code was using Node.js 8.
And you're probably
looking at this thinking,
what's the big deal?
I just saw this.
Why are you repeating yourself?
And that's exactly the
point, is Node 10--
you just change from Node.js
8 to Node.js 10, boom.
You're good to go.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: And we're
good to go hopefully.
Here we go.
So I'm going to deploy
that to US East 1.
While it does that, let's
switch to a different shell.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah
and so again, you're
just deploying the way
you normally would.
And as I mentioned,
you don't need
to know anything about
the function's framework
if you don't want to.
This is what you get
if you actually do know
about the function's framework.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Yeah.
So we're going to
just NPM install.
Any Node.js developer,
this is completely--
you do this time and time again.
Functions framework.
OK.
STEWART REICHLING: So
what's happening here
is you're using the Node
Package Manager to install
this package.
It's going to add it
to your package JSON.
See how that just
showed up line 12?
And now you're saying,
hey, my function
depends on this
function's framework.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: OK.
So that's that installed.
We need to do one more thing.
STEWART REICHLING: OK.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: We need
to add a stop script.
So that's functions framework.
STEWART REICHLING: And I know
in belaboring this point--
as a Node developer, adding
a script, super idiomatic.
It totally fits the
idioms of Node.js.
You should already
know how to do this.
You don't need to learn
any complicated stuff.
And what Justin is doing
here is he's saying,
hey, my star command says
run functions framework, look
for this specific function.
And then he's going to
specify the function signature
type as HTTP.
The reason you do this
is because we also
support an events-based
function signature type.
And you tell us which
signature to use
so that we know how to
transform incoming HTTP
into the right arguments and
invoke your function properly.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: And because
it's completely idiomatic,
we can now just do
the start script.
And what's really cool--
without any emulators,
and I have my function
running locally on my machine.
STEWART REICHLING: It's
just a local development
server the way you
would get if you
were using Flask and Python or
various other web frameworks.
You now have this function
that you can send requests to.
You can very quickly iterate.
Even if you're not
connected to the internet,
you have this thing
running locally.
You can send it requests,
and it will run your code.
So that's kind of cool.
Knowing about the
framework gives you
this very simple local
development experience that
lets you bootstrap a function.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON:
And we should also
have the same function
running on Cloud Functions.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah.
So what you were just
seeing on the screen--
switch back for just a sec.
This is the output you get
after deploying a function.
It describes what just
happened, some characteristics
and attributes of the function.
It also gives you this
URL, the HTTPS trigger URL.
And people who have worked
on provisioning HTTPS URLs
know that this stuff is
actually kind of a pain.
It's not super easy.
But we, through our tooling,
make this super easy for you.
You now have this thing
that you can click.
You can send traffic to it.
You can send HTTP posts, get,
payloads, and it will just run.
And you can grab all
of the stuff that
comes as headers because you're
getting these idiomatic HTTP
objects in Node.js
or in the language
that you wrote your function in.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: The
Functions Framework
isn't just about
running locally, is it?
STEWART REICHLING: Right.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: So let's
go back to the slide deck.
Thank you.
STEWART REICHLING: Thank you.
OK.
So run functions in more places,
local development-- cool.
That's great.
But if this were all
I was showing you,
I feel like you'd
be disappointed,
because the title of the talk is
Run Cloud Functions Everywhere.
And this is just two places.
So where else could
we run our functions?
Well, if you know
about Knative--
and it's not that important
that you know about Knative.
I'll explain it briefly.
You can also run your functions
in Knative environments.
Knative environments
are environments
that run containers that
scale automatically and have--
they're basically server
environments from a developer
experience perspective.
We announced two products
that are Knative environments
at Cloud Next this year.
One of them is Cloud Run.
The other one is
Cloud Run on GKE.
If you don't know
what these are yet,
I'm about to talk about them.
So your Knative environments
basically tell--
it's a standard for
how you run containers
in a serverless manner.
Your functions scale up.
They scale down.
There's a serving API to which
these two products adhere.
And we can now take your
function with the Functions
Framework and run it in
these other container-based
environments.
Let me recap what Cloud Run is
and what Cloud Run on GKE is.
So one is it's
serverless containers.
You build a container using
by-- specifying a Docker file.
You can now run that on our
Cloud Run, our server container
infrastructure.
So you wrote some code.
You wrote a Docker file.
You did Docker
Build, or you built
it using some other product.
And now you deploy that
to our infrastructure.
That will scale
automatically for you.
It takes HTTP requests.
You only pay for the
resources that you use.
You can bring your own
container, as I just mentioned.
You're going to
write a Docker file.
With a Docker file, if you're
not familiar with containers,
it's not that scary,
but it gives you
a huge amount of flexibility.
So you can put in whatever
binaries that you want.
You can specify specific
rules, and it gives you way
more control than
you can get just
by writing some source code.
You can say, hey,
apt get install blah,
and that will allow you to
put custom stuff in there.
And then the last piece is
it says Cloud Run and Cloud
Run on GKE.
And I'd encourage you to
read up on Cloud Run or Cloud
Run on GKE after the talk.
But you have this
common experience
where you can build a
container and deploy it.
You deploy it to
either Cloud Run,
which is a fully
managed environment that
runs on our infrastructure.
It's actually the
same infrastructure
that Cloud Functions runs on.
Or you can deploy it
to Cloud Run on GKE,
which runs inside of your Google
Kubernetes Engine cluster.
And why would you
want to do that?
Well, it gives you an even
bigger degree of control.
And we'll talk about
that in a second.
So you've got these
two environments
that can run containers.
How do I run my function
in those environments?
Well, remember that
Cloud Functions--
when we build your function,
it's really just a container,
at the end of the day, that
runs on our serverless container
infrastructure.
You can take full control
over that container using
the Functions Framework
by specifying a runtime,
by specifying an
operating system.
You can build that
container yourself,
and now you can deploy that to
Cloud Run and Cloud Run on GKE.
So whereas with Cloud
Functions, you just
write some source code,
you type a command,
and you deploy it, if you want
to go down this path, which
I think is a super interesting
path because it gives you
a way more flexibility, you
can write your function code,
add the Functions Framework,
write a Docker file,
build it, and deploy it.
And it's actually quite
a seamless experience.
We'll show you that
in just a second.
Let's switch now another demo.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: OK.
So same function,
slightly modified.
If we're going to
have a function
and we want to make
it portable, we
don't want to have
hardcoded strings.
So I've just used an environment
variable with a backup
just in case I forget to set
the environment variable.
That's never happened.
STEWART REICHLING: So
yeah, pretty much the exact
same thing, except
line 10, rather
than saying hello Cloud
Next, it takes this message
which in line 1 says, hey, check
for this environment variable,
or no message set.
We're going to set the
environment variable.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: OK.
So I'm going to deploy this
with the environment variable.
Because I've already
deployed this function,
I don't need to
specify the runtime.
You can do.
But I'm going to do region.
STEWART REICHLING: Why
don't you add the runtime?
I think you'll look
better on video later.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: OK.
I'll add the runtime.
OK.
So now we just need to set
the environment variable.
That's all we need to do.
STEWART REICHLING:
If you don't do this,
it's just going to
say no message set.
It's not going to
be a very nice demo.
So please set it.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: OK.
I think that will do.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Let's
go ahead and deploy that.
STEWART REICHLING: This is
the same deployment command
as earlier, except we're also
specifying the environment
variable.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: OK.
[INAUDIBLE] while that deploys.
OK.
Let's deploy to Cloud Run.
The very first thing we
need is a Docker file,
super simple Docker file.
There's more comments in here
than actual actions they run.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah.
There's, like, five or six lines
that you actually write in.
This is a totally standard
Node.js Docker file.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Yeah.
And so we're taking
Node.js 10 base image?
STEWART REICHLING: From the top.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Yeah,
Node.js 10 base image,
creating the location to run--
STEWART REICHLING: That's
your operating system.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Yeah, that
includes the operating system
and the runtime binary node.
And then we copy
the package JSON.
We do that in a separate step.
Because if you don't actually
update your dependencies,
we don't want to rebuild that
layer in the Docker container.
We copied the function across,
and then we have our NPM start
like we had running it locally.
STEWART REICHLING: OK.
So you specify the
operating system.
You copy stuff into there.
You do NPM install to make sure
the dependencies are installed
inside of that container.
And then on line 20, this is
just the command that will be
run when your
container starts up .
And now Justin is
using Docker, which--
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: On the machine.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah,
on the local machine.
You could also build
this in the cloud.
Docker is the standard container
building and management tool
chain.
And he's saying,
build my container,
and he gives it a name.
That container gets
built. You could
see that was super fast,
because a lot of stuff
is already cached, because
we've done this before.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Maybe.
STEWART REICHLING:
And then he's going
to take that container,
which he built locally,
and he's going to put that
on Google Container Registry.
Google Container
Registry is just a place
that stores containers for you.
So right now, he's
uploading that container.
It's going to be on
Google Container Registry
if it has a name.
So he went from function source
code, added the Docker file,
built the container,
pushed it, and now it's
ready to be deployed.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: So cloud run.
It's beta, so we
need to add the beta.
OK.
This should be
looking very familiar.
If your functions-- if you're
used to gcloud with functions,
this is very familiar.
STEWART REICHLING: Run to--
it said functions.
Now it says run.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON:
Yeah, that's it.
And instead of the
function we want to invoke,
we just need to give
it a service name.
It will-- if I can type--
it will remind
you if you forget.
I've done that lots.
And I'm going to deploy this
to a different region, US.
Let's go to US Central.
We need the image.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah.
So rather than specifying
a runtime here,
he's saying, hey,
just take my image
from Google Container
Registry with this name.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: And then
again, very, very familiar,
and in fact, absolutely
identical to what we just did.
In Cloud Functions, we set
the environment variables.
And this time, we want
to say hello from.
STEWART REICHLING: OK.
So what's going to happen here
is once he enters this command,
Cloud Run is going to
go and fetch that image
and deploy it to the
Cloud Run infrastructure.
We do many of the same
things that we showed earlier
where we take that
image, we start it,
we make sure it's healthy, we
start to spin it up for you.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: And there's
one difference here--
by default, services in
Cloud Run are private.
But for the sake
of this demo, we're
going to say let's
allow unauthenticated.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah.
If you didn't do
that, it would just
give us an error, which
should make for a bad demo
when we try to--
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: OK.
So we've got another
environment we can deploy to.
Now I'm going to deploy that
same function into Kubernetes.
So let's sharpen the YAML tools.
No, we don't need to.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah.
If you've used
Kubernetes before,
you know you have to write a
lot of YAML to deploy something.
One of the really nice
things about having
Cloud Run and Cloud Run
on GKE is Cloud Run on GKE
is Kubernetes under the
hood, but you don't have
to actually write any YAML.
You get out very seamless
developer experience using
gcloud, the command line tool.
And by the way, you can do
all this stuff in the UI
too, in the user interface.
We're just using gcloud because
it lends itself well to a demo,
and we see that pattern
a lot among developers.
And so to do this,
Justin, before this talk,
set up a Google
Kubernetes Engine cluster.
You can do that via the UI.
That thing is now sitting there.
He installed into
that Cloud Run on GKE,
and it's sitting
there waiting for him
to deploy a container to it.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: OK.
So you can see this
is identical, really.
So far there is no difference.
OK.
We're going to say
hello from Cloud Run.
STEWART REICHLING: You'll
see why we're setting
the environment variables.
When we show you
these things running,
it's going to show you this
message just so you can make
sure that we're not faking it.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Yeah.
And the last thing
we need to do is
we need to actually
say which cluster
do we want to deploy into.
STEWART REICHLING: OK.
So rather than saying,
hey, region, which region
would be a region--
one of the ones supported in
Cloud Run and Google's data
centers, he's going to say,
hey, this cluster, which he's
called cloud-run-gke,
is where I want
to deploy this function to.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: And we need to
tell it where the master node
lives, which is in US West 1A.
OK.
Let's just double check.
And we get-- so that's
going to play that out
into my Kubernetes cluster.
Exactly the same
if I'm a developer
and I have an [INAUDIBLE]
looking after my GKE cluster.
I don't need to worry
about all of that.
It's a serverless experience.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah,
that's a good point.
Cloud Run on GKE, well, you
have to have a GKE cluster.
It's not as managed as the
Cloud Run experience is.
If you already have
a cluster, It's
a great way to actually get
started and get as much as you
can out of your functions.
If you don't have a cluster yet,
the easiest way to try to stuff
out is to just go for Cloud Run,
because that's fully managed.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Yep.
OK.
So let's just recap.
We've deployed to three
different environments
with exactly the same function.
The only difference was
the environment variables.
And we've gone to Cloud
Functions, Cloud Run--
STEWART REICHLING: Well, you
wrote a little Docker file too.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Yeah, I did.
STEWART REICHLING: But yeah,
it's the same function code.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: We didn't
have to change the actual code
at all.
STEWART REICHLING: Exactly.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: OK.
So hopefully, if the domain
gods are playing nicely,
we should say hello
from GCF and US West.
STEWART REICHLING: OK.
You got a nice HTTPS URL
that you can invoke there.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: And
then we go to Cloud Run,
and we head across
the US to US Central.
And we should have another URL.
STEWART REICHLING:
Serving traffic at-- yep,
it gives you another URL.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Yep.
There we go-- hello
cloud run in US Central.
And then finally, we
had the same going
into my Kubernetes,
cluster which is here,
which I've already set up.
If we come to here and
we paste that in there--
STEWART REICHLING: Nice.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Hello from
Cloud Run on GKE in US West.
STEWART REICHLING: OK, cool.
So you just took the same
code, you added a framework,
and you added a Docker
file, and you deployed it
to three different environments.
So we've established
that you have portability
among these environments when
you're using the Functions
Framework and you just
want to write functions.
Can we go back to
the slides, please?
So your functions are portable.
You can run them
on Cloud Functions.
You can run them locally.
You can run them on these
different environments.
But what's the big deal, right?
Portability-- so what?
Who cares?
Well, for one,
these environments
are all serverless, which
means you have a very
simple developer experience.
You have auto scaling to
meet traffic up and down.
You have HTTP triggers
where you have a URL
that you can hit to
make your function run.
Then you also don't have
to manage infrastructure.
And I'd be kind of lying if
I put a little green check
in the bottom right box.
You do have to
manage a GKE cluster.
It's still significantly
easier than if you
tried to do this
yourself, but just
be aware that if you want
to do Cloud Run in GKE,
you have to have a GKE cluster.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: But there's
a good reason for using--
we haven't really touched
on if we're using like GKE.
If you wanted to
particularly use GPUs--
like say--
STEWART REICHLING: I'm
going to get to that.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Oh, OK.
STEWART REICHLING:
That's coming.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Oh,
that's for your show.
STEWART REICHLING: OK.
So how do you think about these
three different environments?
The first one-- Cloud
Functions go from source code
to a running function
within minutes.
What we just showed
you is pretty simple.
You write a couple lines,
issue a command, boom.
You're good to go.
Cloud Run-- why would you
want to do it on Cloud Run?
Well, when you write
that Docker file,
you can put arbitrary
stuff in there.
It gives you
fine-grained control
over what actually goes
inside of the container.
Maybe you need a
very specific binary.
Maybe you need to have stuff
built in a certain way.
Well, if you write
a Docker file,
build it, deploy
to Cloud Run, you
have an autoscaling function
that includes whatever custom
stuff you need to put in there.
So it gives you more
flexibility, more power,
a little bit more
responsibility in terms
of what you put into that Docker
file, but also more power.
Cloud Run on GKE, very
similar sort of story.
You can run it now in
a self-managed cluster.
Within that cluster,
your function
will scale up and
scale down according
to the size of your cluster.
And that cluster can
obviously grow, too,
as your needs change.
But you can run it in that
cluster with even more control.
For example, you need
specialized instance types
like GPUs.
Now you can have this
function code that you wrote,
deployed it to Cloud
Run on GKE where
you have an instance
pool that includes GPUs
or more CPUs, specialized
instance types.
And your function can
use those resources.
And so this is a pretty
cool way of thinking
about the portability aspect,
is I can write my function code
once, and I realize,
hey, I actually
need this specialized thing.
OK.
Well, I can move it to Cloud
Run, and I can do that.
Maybe I need something
even more specialized.
I can move it to
Cloud Run on GKE,
and I can do that
too without needing
to change my function code.
As we start to wrap
up, I just want
to highlight that this
is just a first step.
What we showed you
here is just Node 10.
I'm sure a lot of
people in the audience
also want Python, Go, Java.
All of the runtimes
that we support
on Cloud Functions,
the new ones that we're
going to be releasing, are based
on this Functions Framework
model that's going to give
you that nice local developer
experience.
It's going to give you that
portability to different cloud
environments.
Hey, one thing I
should call out, too,
is I showed Cloud Run on
GKE, and I mentioned earlier
that these are
Knative environments.
There are other
Knative environments
provided by companies
that are not Google.
IBM, for example, has
a Knative environment.
The container that you build
can run on that environment too.
So this isn't just portability
within Google Cloud.
It's also portability among
Knative environments provided
by other providers.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON:
Or even on premise.
STEWART REICHLING: Yes.
You can run Knative in
your cluster on premises,
and you can run
your function there.
So back to the runtimes.
All new runtimes that
we're going to be releasing
are going to follow this model.
I'll give you that local
developer experience.
It'll give you that portability.
Python, we're planning
to-- when Python 3.8 comes,
out that's going
to be a Functions
Framework-based model.
We also see this Functions
Framework as a great way
that we can start to integrate
additional functionality
into your functions.
So one example here is I want
to be able to see my trace data.
Imagine I have three or four
functions calling each other.
I want to see the
lifecycle of a request
as it passes through
those different functions
so that I can see which
one takes the longest.
Where does this
thing get caught up?
We can add those
things to the module--
that is, the
Functions Framework--
so that in each language,
you suddenly get
this functionality,
for free, built in.
And when I say
free, these services
do sometimes have
a cost, but I mean
that you don't have to actually
add this boilerplate code
to every one of your functions.
It just comes nicely integrated.
And then also, a lot of the
talk today was based on HTTP.
We also support events, so
an event style signature.
And we do have more work to
do on bringing these events
to other platforms.
But we're working
with the CNCF, which
is the Cloud Native Computing
Foundations CloudEvents spec.
So we support that today.
If you send CloudEvents
to the function,
the Functions Framework
will automatically
convert those into objects
relevant to your language.
And these are the
pieces that we think
are really key to providing
a good functions experience.
It should be easy.
It should be well integrated
so that you don't have
to write a bunch boilerplate.
It should support
events, obviously.
And we think we
can do all of this
through the Functions Framework.
So with that, as
we wrap up, there
are a couple of
sessions that I'd
point you to if you
want to learn more
about what you saw today.
Most of these have
already happened,
but they're going
to be up on YouTube
as well if they're
not up already.
So what's new in serverless
compute goes much more
into App Engine, Cloud
Functions, Cloud Run,
what's all the new stuff.
Some really cool demos
in there, too, that
show us scaling up from zero
to almost 10,000 instances
to handle a request
load within, like,
five seconds, which is
pretty mind-blowing.
We also have a Cloud
Run session which
will go much deeper on how you
actually use this product, what
are the features, and a Cloud
Run on GKE session-- similar,
but about Cloud Run on GKE.
So with that, I
want to say thanks.
Some links here.
This is all going
to be up on YouTube
if you need to
capture those later.
Cloud Functions docs, also the
Functions Framework Repository,
which is live today on
GitHub, and the Cloud Run
docs, great ways to get
familiar with the products.
Your feedback
greatly appreciated.
As I said at the beginning,
please add it to the app.
Tell me what you liked.
Tell me what we can
do better next time.
This is super helpful to me.
And I will leave
these private alphas.
These are QR codes for the Go
1.12 runtime and the Java 8
runtime.
These will lead you to forms.
If you fill those out--
we're adding people
on a weekly basis.
We can add more people.
We can get you added
to those as well.
And if you miss these,
come get me later.
They'll also be on the video
that's hosted on YouTube.
[MUSIC PLAYING]